hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
law breakers the team-based arena Tudor
is almost here in fact its release date
is August the 8th it's a high-speed
shooter with extremely fluid gameplay
reliving the awesome first-person
shooters from yesteryear it feels like
quake arena and Unreal Tournament
inflective which makes it a brilliant
nostalgia hit for us all days and it has
enough modern elements to make it
desirable for a contemporary audience to
care 7 things we think you should know
about this
set on earth after a huge event has
destroyed the moon thus effecting
gravity here on earth
a few devious criminals known as
breakers are attempting to take
advantage of the situation and the law
enforcement are here to stop them the
premise is really here to bring
attention to the low gravity sections of
each level each character's ability to
move in and out of these areas whether
that's by floating jumping using gunfire
to maneuver or by utilising jetpacks if
the fuel is available or using abilities
like grappling hooks for additional
speed so the name lawbreakers refers to
both the crafty criminals and the laws
of physics that are being thrown out of
the window even the [ __ ] vultures
mauricio the pocket of anti-gravity make
verticality so important in winning
matches so don't keep your boots on the
ground for too long once you've figured
out movement in each level then accuracy
with your weapons becomes the main focus
each character has their own arsenal
with pros and cons free to their weapons
the four cornerstones of lawbreakers are
the enforcers the Vanguard the Titans
and the assassin class the enforcers are
the well-rounded assault class which is
probably the easiest class to start with
the Titans are the tanks with an
extended life pool and big-ass weaponry
definitely made for the front lines the
Vanguard class is built for speed and
agility and the assassins are the melee
focused choice with a small health bar
which can be refilled with each sword
attack you successfully lanced of course
there's so much more to these classes
and I'll break those down once we get
the full game relief hybrid characters
are being introduced regularly with a
total of 16 characters in the version we
played there's something for everyone
here and if you're coming from overwatch
there's many of the abilities you are
used to seeing there plus many more from
other titles and some completely new
skills to get you thinking - my personal
favorite or rather the character I
gravitated towards is the race with high
mobility and course of melee action but
with a decent amount of weapon range
when rushing in isn't really an option
this vector pistol may not look that
impressive certain sure packs a punch
once you've played a few games and you
figured out how everything works you'll
find the best character for you as you'd
expect with the game of this type
customisation is king each character has
an ever-growing so
election of cosmetic items to unlock or
buy with in-game currency you've seen
loot boxes 101 times before whether
that's in csgo overwatch or even
paladins
the stash boxes in lawbreakers include
gear which have levels of rarity ranging
from base level through to exotic of
boss character skins have a range of
options with the exotic version changing
more than just the color scheme my race
can even look like a hybrid of Deadpool
and star-lord from guardians of the
galaxy damn sexy I'm sure you'll agree
the customization stretches further than
the character skins with decals and
stickers for your weapons in this case
it has taken elements from Counter
Strike global Offensive with guns like
the cz-75 red aster seemingly recreated
there's a range of other elements to
customize with my favorite being the
footprint you leave on another person
screen when you kick them square in the
face there's more strictly group the
game modes that I've seen so far are
reasonably buried overcharge is probably
my favorite with a single battery being
on the map at all times each team
attempts to take the battery to their
respective charging stations and hold on
to it until it's fully charged and then
defend it for a further 20 seconds if
the battery is stolen by the other team
you will keep your progression so if you
guys have charged it to 60% and then
it's stolen once you get it back it will
still be set to 60% you don't have to
start again other game types include
uplink and blitzball which shall like
capture the flag in rift if your destiny
player oh and turf you are - which is a
typical control match with three points
to capture the twist here is that the
zones refresh and must be warned
repeatedly if you are a hardcore video
game fan you have probably heard of
clicky being well Cliff Bleszinski the
mastermind behind such games as Gears of
War jazz jackrabbit Unreal Tournament
bat princess and bullet storm is back
with boss key studios to have such a
hugely successful designer at the core
of the project should indicate a long
and fruitful support period after the
game [ __ ] law breakers has confirmed
that all DLC will be free - which is
nice to hear in modern gaming isn't it
law breakers hits the PC and ps4 on
August II 8 this is a console exclusive
so our Xbox and switch for
sisters won't be able to get their hands
on this just yet
this will set you back $30 off 30 euros
and 25 pounds in the UK although that
still hasn't been confirmed so let's
hope we don't get overcharged here in
Britain one last little note all the
footage seen in this video was captured
on a standard ps4 so if you've got a pro
expect a few upgrades what do you think
the lawbreakers are you one for
fast-paced arena shooters or do you
prefer the slower more tactical ones I'm
still undecided at present so I'm going
to go back and plays now anyway please
let me know your thoughts below I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade and I've always
been a pleasure
[Music]
you